[Musique]
ça vous dérange pas que je m'assoie avec
vous vous êtes le détective le plus
célèbre du monde hercule poirot le
vengeur des innocents comme la presse
vous appelle et vous êtes une sans vous
êtes marrants
un passager est mort assassiné le
meurtrier parmi nous en ce moment dans
ce train et chacun d'entre vous et
suspect trouveront l'assassin
la nommer venus fouiller dans ma cabine
en plein milieu de la nuit
vous êtes certaine tous internes que je
sais ce que c'est que d'avoir un homme
dans sa chambre et vous que pensez-vous
de la rocqué m'a laissé lander de ça
avait-il des ennemis plein d'ennemis
véritable assassin se trouve ici il est
parmi vos
une somme mise en cercle et par les
mensonges
je vais dormir ici où tout le monde
pourra me voir
et où je pourrai voir chacun d'entre
vous qui s'est emparée du coupon
ne faites confiance à personne personne